dog the bounty hunter's daughter bonnie
joe is speaking out against her father
who she claims didn't invite her to his
upcoming wedding and is because of her
support of social justice issues
including the black lives matter
movement
i am a law man on a mission from god on
monday the 22 year old daughter of the
famous bounty hunter whose real name is
dwayne chapman released this lengthy
statement to facebook where she said in
part i'm sorry but i can't defend my
dad's racism
in the message she reacts to a recent
tnz story about their family drama and
claims her dad's fiancee francie fran
revealed why she and her sister cecily
were not invited to their big day
a rep for dwayne and francie said in a
statement to et bonnie's allegations are
false and a misguided attempt to derail
our wedding according to bonnie joe
she'd been participating in an online
video series called the system
which she said focused on social justice
advocacy and protesting violence and
racial bias by police
bonnie joe claims dwayne was fired from
the series on account of his use of
racial and homophobic epithets toward
her co-stars
bonnie joe claimed a text message from
francie revealed the reason i wasn't
invited to my dad's wedding is my choice
to participate in social justice and blm
protests with the system and not condemn
the streaming platform when they fired
my father for using epithets
in her statement bonnie joe goes on to
make several other allegations against
her father including that he frequently
cheated on her late mother beth chapman
even having an affair with one of beth's
friends while she was in the hospital in
addition bonnie joe said dwayne has
called blm protesters thugs and has used
horrific language towards the lgbtq plus
community
bonnie wrote i was scared of not being
invited to family gatherings however i
know my mom would never stand for this
and it is in honor of her legacy that i
speak out
i kneel
for the cross and stand for the flag and
she's like
you know so i knelt down and said
francie would you marry me and she said
yes
we'll pick a date later
e.t sat down with dwayne and francie in
september of last year where they spoke
about their engagement you have a new
happy part of your life yes
yes what is that well you know uh
my bath passed over a year ago one day i
was praying and i looked in genesis and
lo and behold i looked down and was
reading it said because i was trying to
find out what adam did to get eve
you know she's up there dancing with
angels and stuff i'm down here bawling
every day yeah and i read the bible said
in the old testament genesis
for god does not want a man to be alone
and so i start saying uh oh
if beth was left here and i went to
heaven
as long as it was a christian and he
owned an airplane
i would approve
it so uh my francie doesn't own an
airplane but she's a great christian so
god
gave me a second chance
all right i see that beautiful ring tell
me about the engagement because
you set everything up didn't you yeah
well you know it's not my first rodeo no
david in the bible was married eight
times
this is your last time
yeah the uh you buy two my gary boy said
dad welcome to the girl gets two rings
so after the wedding then i she has
another one so
how did you propose tell me about that i
got down on one knee and said francie
frame will you marry me
and i said can i i'm saying it so i said
listen when i get down then i want you
to
get down too on your knee and help me
back up
right
like you i'm getting down so are you
mama
and so i got down and she's like
standing there i was crying and nervous
and you did she didn't even pull me back
up i had to limp up
that's not true you're exaggerating
whatever he did a great job and it was
really romantic and he did get down i
did tell him
months before because he kept saying to
me
um i'm not letting you go out of my life
so you're gonna marry me one day
and so i kept saying to him we'll see
about that
so then that day
he got down on one knee
and asked me if i would marry him
you